Печеня з індички в Англії, шинка у Швеції та смажений гусак у Німеччині.
У багатьох країнах Європи на Різдво подають ситне м'ясо.
При цьому всі різдвяні рецепти дуже різні. Втім, як і готові страви на смак.
Печеня з індички вважається у Великобританії різдвяною класикою.
Цю страву можна знайти у святковому меню більшості ресторанів Лондона.
Привіт! Я - Метт Бішоп. І сьогодні ми готуємо типову різдвяну індичку.
Найкраще для цього рецепту підійде грудинка індички. Але не тільки!
Попередньо тушку обробили. М'ясо відділили, подрібнили та приправили.
Пізніше воно буде використовуватися як начинка.
Зовні печеня обгортають у шинку - це робить її більш соковитою.
М'ясу необхідно дати трохи постояти, а потім відправити на дві години до духовки.
Раджу готувати цію стравуи на день раніше. Тоді м'ясо настоїться, просочиться і залишиться лише розігріти його. На це піде не більше години.
Те саме стосується і гарнірів: картоплі, пастернаку, брюссельської капусти та невеликих сосисок, загорнутих у бекон.
Зрештою, час має вирішальне значення, адже так хочеться, щоб на свята все пройшло ідеально.
За допомогою термометра можна перевірити, чи готова смаженя.
У середині має бути 72 градуси за Цельсієм.
Так готується ідеальна британська індичка до різдвяного столу.
А у Швеції на строкатому святковому столі - різдвяна шинка. Як тут, у Гетеборзі.
Я - Ульф Вагнер, щасливий власник ресторану Sjömagasinet.
Сьогодні ми познайомимося зі шведським різдвяним столом.
І я покажу вам, як приготувати шинку - юльхінку. Поїхали!
Бульйон приправляють цибулею та гвоздикою, а також додають лавровий лист та білий перець.
Шинка вариться близько 90 хвилин.
Чудово!
Потім м'ясо має трохи охолонути, після чого з нього зрізається зайвий жир.
Для соусу змішують яєчні жовтки, кисло-солодку гірчицю та цукор.
Але перш ніж шинку покриють цим соусом, її обвалюють у панірувальних сухарях.
Я завжди обвалюю м'ясо в панірувальних сухарях, перш ніж покрити його соусом.
Потім на шинку викладаємо соус із гірчиці і панірувальні сухарі, що залишилися.
У попередньо розігрітій духовці м'ясо запікається протягом декількох хвилин,
доки сухарі не стануть золотисто-коричневими.
І ось будь ласка, шинка "юльхінка" готова!
Уммм! Лише погляньте! Яка красуня!
Тонко нарізаній шинці "юльхінка" відводиться головна роль на шведському святковому столі.
Крім інших делікатесів до святкового столу чудово підійде і пляшечка гльогга -
скандинавського варіанта глінтвейну. На здоров'я!
А в Німеччині типовою різдвяною стравою вважається смажений гусак.
У ресторані "Роттнер" у баварському Нюрнберзі цю традиційну страву можна скуштувати вже задовго до свята.
Мене звати Штефан Роттнер, я представляю романтичний готель та ресторан Роттнер тут, у Нюрнберзі.
І сьогодні ми смажимо гусака. А до нього приготуємо червонокачанну капусту та кльоцки.
Найголовніше - правильний вибір гусака.
Найкраще, якщо його вирощували в екологічних умовах на вільному вигулі.
Вибирати треба з розрахунку близько кілограма на порцію.
А фарширувати гусака будемо дрібно нарізаними яблуками, цибулею, селерою та імбиром.
Усередині та зовні м'ясо натирають перцем та сіллю, фарширують і ставлять у духовку спочатку на 30 хвилин.
Тим часом займімося гарніром.
У цьому регіоні Німеччини традиційно подають картопляні кльоцки.
Поділимося невеликим секретом: вони готуються із суміші вареної картоплі
з додаванням приблизно чверті від загальної маси - сирої картоплі.
Кльоцки варяться у солоній воді приблизно 20 хвилин.
Повернімося до нашого гусака. Щоб м'ясо не пересихало, кожні 5 хвилин його треба поливати бульйоном.
Далі ще приблизно дві з половиною години м'ясо запікається до хрусткої скоринки.
Найсмачніше, якщо подати готового різдвяного гусака до столу гарячим прямо з духовки.
Як-то кажуть, ґутен апетіт - смачного!